you are welcome to this video Marta
Marta bollocks Marta bollocks from from
you came he's playing the c3 is saying
I'm going to play this assay in here as
I'm may be mentioned in a video the
video before that i'm not quite sure I
check my statistics and have held out
that I mean I looked at my results with
what kind of openings I had what results
and her fantastic squad necessary and so
should try to play this opening a little
bit more ok i played this line mmm it's
kind of interesting yeah one idea of
this is this funny Bishop f5 movers that
you sometimes just heck this and say
okay you can f two bishops but I will
have a good control over them over the
center with the Queen that's a kind of
embarrassing move from the windy 7
there's Bishop b5 ah and I didn't think
about the Queen shaqeeya mm-hmm King d8
but
King the idea this looks looks really
horrible yeah what I'm wondering about
is if I should if I should check the
Queen for two pieces King the a drug
takes p.m. one this will probably not
contribute much to my good score with a
cesarean Wow cannot remember having such
a bad position after dead moose who that
is not good okay maybe it's not so easy
for him maybe at least the Queen on d5
looks somewhat like an annoyance ya
later this is controlling some important
squares yeah probably taking on d4 was
the rubbish idea and this whole sequence
was probably really bad but okay let's
see what happens if it is that terrible
now move like Bishop Bishop audia Bishop
c4 and so on i can maybe just really
take on g2 as bad as it looks but maybe
i can do that yeah he's really is really
preparing that come on let's let's start
with this trying to get the night to d5
as a as a blockade am I don't really
have good square CF may be here for
Queen B form if I get Queens traded this
is not this is half as bad really here
come on let's try to trade Queens if he
wants to avoid the Queen trade he has to
do something that he does not want to do
Quincy to Queen d1 or not good moose 21
I can just take the bishop of course
sorry and Quincy to look yet so it
probably has to try Quincy okay this is
not as bad oopsie ATM doesn't b5 now on
winning the bishop then you can go to a
5 maybe I can go to a 3 down
so I will win this edition right yeah I
guess I will
yeah good good good he's taking quite
some time so it it's not like I'm super
hard behind on time that's helpful so
what is he doing now I mean my king is
not safe but it doesn't look like i
should be mated quickly yeah this is the
way I played this opening really was was
not good at all okay let's take it how
to do this now yeah my kingdom may be
here for nye g for this kind of thing
with a check yeah maybe still or queen
a6 not double attacking that's not bad
right taking c forum and the rook and if
i get see for this would be very very
important as it also gets me then the d5
square for the night and it prevents his
paws from just going forward yeah it's
good now I mean had a extra piece before
but it looks like I'm starting to
coordinate a little bit i also had
Knight g4 which wasn't stupid probably
with a check then taking on gt5 but that
gets affords really this is a huge
progress still the Queen the King on the
eighth hmm yeah he's probably a bit
frustrated after my completely a moronic
opening that he's not winning but
somehow he is in them it's not not
really fair this game sometimes
ok so is I am ok it's not now that sets
its in fact let's in fact still quite
tricky let's try to double on the
seventh no no tea for a g4 are not
helping time morning Roxy a drug one to
be seven it's not clear
amazing
this is not clear not at all
TX Bishop cheeks you can take on f7 I'll
give the check on design
I wonder them overlooking some made on
it can easily be possible it looks looks
kind of kind of tricky here white
forfeits on time yeah I don't know it
still wasn't easy at least in a
practical game but the computer is not
seeing something quickly which means
that probably isn't anything Bishop g2
now was good ah threatening Bishop a5
interesting Bishop g2 so h6 was a
mistake I have to play here and I'm
winning I didn't think about that
because i thought this check and then
here why isn't this good night see Sapna
computer chess to computer chess and
then not something strapped him well
they're impossible to see no not with 20
seconds again this this is this is now
really losing he had to go to d2 and now
here this is this is a really big
annoyance is true this threat if I'm
doing this check check that's the
problem
yeah okay well I had a completely
original aust position here probably it
is just a very bad idea to do this as I
did and I yeah I have to do something
else yeah I don't know what maybe
castling long even or something but but
not what I did yeah this is I was not
really considering she takes d4 that
much and of course this is just very
valid gem winning a tempo again this
this no I mean probably I'm losing him
this is just so bad with the king Jim so
somehow this is not clear and here
winning winning the piece what did we
had game and I wanted who okay well
thanks for watching